adriano uh valentino from australia said
trump is an uncomfortable con man
question mark sank you're a sociopath
the next guy responds and says at least
he's a con man at least he's not a
politician which is pretty anxious well
that last one's kind of true yeah at
least he's a professional yeah so so
we'll we'll take collins uh in the last
30 minutes probably so just stay tuned
and tyler if you want to put the number
there for some people that want to call
in in the super chats but let me
continue okay so can i address the con
man thing real quick sure of course i
mean look he's been adjudicated and
admitted to being a con man both his
charity and his university were giant
scams and he had to pay huge fines 25
million dollar fine because he was
running scams almost everything he runs
as a scam and by the way does everybody
know that he's gone bankrupt six times
that he's an awful awful businessman
couldn't manage his way out of a wet
paper bag
biggest dumb ass i've ever seen in
business what he did in atlantic city it
didn't just sink his own companies he
sank the entire city he's one of the
worst businessman in american history
and by the way you see the incompetence
of the democratic party that they
couldn't point out those simple facts
when they were running let me ask you
this what's harder to do okay be honest
let's see i'm really curious what you're
going to say you think it's harder to be
a senator for 50 years
or do you think it's harder to be in
free enterprise free market capitalism
competition in new york for 50 years
what's harder to do
well trump has proved that
the economy is much harder because he
went bankrupt so many times it must be
really really hard well jack but but
wait wait a minute but the point is it
is
it is a there's a big difference between
me being in the arena and getting my ass
kicked but at least i'm getting in the
arena versus being a fan on the outside
and i'm booing the guy in the arena
let's give some credibility to the guy
that's got the balls to be in the arena
fighting houses of free market patrick i
give you credit i give me credit yeah
we're in the arena and we built these
things on our own okay so ben shapiro i
don't agree with his politics but he
built daily wire and it's a real
business now it said i give credit okay
crowder i don't think takes big money
and i think he did it on his own i give
a lot of credit trump had his dad hand
him 413 million dollars he spoils he's a
spoiled little [ __ ] okay and he blew
the whole 413 million dollars because
he's a [ __ ] i give him zero credit kids
yes okay when you when your kids when
you die and you have a living trust
you're a smart guy i'm sure you got a
living trust i'm sure you got all that
stuff in place when god forbid something
happens to you and that money and the
business goes to them are you going to
call your kills a spoiled whatever
whatever because they're going to get
your money no no no no there's a
difference what do you do with the money
so if my kids then use it to do good in
the world or to just set up a business
etc then that's great if they take it
and they go daddy gave me the money i'm
going to put my name all over atlantic
city
and then they are spoiled and they
make fun of other people while actually
not doing anything not doing the
homework i can't even read
i'd be embarrassed if my kids were
anywhere near as lazy and dumb as donald
trump they can't read past the page they
used to have the presidential briefings
that were just three four pages they had
to boil it down to a page because he
would lose attention because because the
because uh but because the guy is
dealing with so many different things
that he typically wants to have the one
page instead of the 50 pages but no
let's make a quick point on trump yeah
okay this might shock some of the people
i'm not a trump fan i don't know you
know probably not my politics i mean
i've there's a lot of people here
that think i'm a crazy socialist
left-wing because i'm just not a trump
fan i'm a capitalist and i like what you
said about democratic capitalism i'd
like to come back to that at some point
but again not a trump fan
but what i am willing to do is at least
give him credit for some positive things
that he's done
as an example
you're giving him zero credit bro i will
say as much as i don't like seeing him
on tv he's a great marketer i can say
that guy's a freaking brilliant marketer
he gets eyeballs he knows how to play
the media he knows how to rattle cages
like i'm at least willing to give him
credit for the things he does well and
even if it's for policies i'll say look
can't stand the guy but policies wise
he's done some good things are you
saying that there's zero credits zero
whatsoever
no i'm not saying that everything is
situational people get into uh which
camp are you in are you left right biden
probing antibiotics so for example i
think biden's doing a great job on
ukraine i think he did a terrible job on
domestic politics total failure in
domestic politics so we can get back
into that later so why because it
depends on the facts so trump i remember
in the beginning there was a plan in
indiana and he threatened a bunch of
politicians and he threatened a bunch of
businesses and it looked like they were
going to stay and i remember doing a
video at an airport because i i liked
that so much because then msnbc was
crying oh my god can you believe he's
threatening people that god damn right
the president's supposed to use carrots
and sticks and he was using sticks
effectively now unfortunately
that one as with almost all of them was
just marketing and then that plant
actually outsourced all the jobs later
and trump didn't do a goddamn thing
about it it's all fake etc so but if on
rare occasions that but for example he
didn't start any new wars great i'll
take it i'll take it right there's no
reason for me to disagree with someone
if they're agreeing with me
oh it's because it's trump you have to
call it bad no that doesn't make any
sense you show me a sensible policy and
i'll be in favor if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]